the Joe Rogan experience well what is it
we have a giant problem in this country
with this hole right left set [ __ ] you
know and this is what I was trying to
say earlier when we're talking about the
concept of classical liberals because
most people don't even know what the
[ __ ] that means the idea behind it I
just think that to have groups of people
that think in certain ways the problem
with ideology is whether it's
left-leaning or right leaning is it
makes you automatically predisposed to
ignore or to refute the concepts that
are on the other side and those and so
many of us share these ideas across the
board and when one group is committed to
one concept like one of the things that
you do see this about climate change
people on the right are more inclined to
deny the negative effects of climate
change because it's part of the right
wing the right wing ideology this is
something we see today I need to get so
you're right but also I would just
advise people don't get too lost in the
noise because we can think that that's
something that's overwhelming and we
can't defeat it and we could also think
that you know for example the whole
Russia Gate thing on the Democratic side
yeah that was that became such a
fundamentalist religion and you couldn't
do those exciting
that's what we wanted it to be true and
people would believe it and argue for it
even though the things weren't adding up
and I was trying to point out where it's
wrong but what I would say is at the end
of the day people should actually be
relatively happy about the fact that I
think the most the strongest divide in
the country is not right versus left the
strongest divide in the country I've
called it populist versus elitist yeah
so you have elitists in the Democratic
Party you have elitist in the Republican
Party and you have the people and the
people are we're so much more in
agreement than people give us credit for
you know I agree I have a thing that I
go down and I did this in some of my
events at Politico as well but people
would be surprised man 80% of the
country wants to raise the minimum wage
58% of the country wants to have free
college like I said only 16% or so of
the American people want to be involved
in Iraq and Afghanistan and these
terrible Foreign Wars sixty-two percent
of the country wants to legalize
marijuana I could sit here and ring off
issue after issue it's over 80 percent
of the American people that want to get
the money out of the political system
and clean
option do you think that this country
has room for other parties we are so
ingrained in this idea of left versus
right Democrat versus Republican and
this is the choices that we've always
had with the occasional independent the
occasional you know Ross Perot jumps
into the race and throws a monkey wrench
into everything but other than that or
maybe in an amount to minor extent Gary
Johnson but do you think there's room
for other parties at this juncture so
that's a great question and what I would
say is first let me give my personal
take on it my personal take is i 100%
want that to be the case because i
prefer in many ways aspects of a
parliamentary system to our system and i
like the idea of having multiple parties
i like the idea of having more choice so
i want that to be true and when i was
one of the cofounders of justice
democrats when we launched it we had to
have those difficult conversations about
how exactly do we go about trying to get
these ideas implemented right and
basically we came to the conclusion that
as much as we want it to be true as much
as we'd like to start a third party and
have it work and take off there is such
a gigantic systemic bias against that
happening that you really do have
ultimately the choice of republican or
democrat so then the idea becomes okay
it's a reform movement now we have to
try to reform the democratic party and
there are people on the right who can
try to reform the republican party like
if you're somebody on the right and you
agree more with ron paul and you're more
libertarian you want to end the wars you
want to legalize drugs i hope those
people take over the republican party
and you have people who are against like
corporate welfare and whatnot in that
party so what we really need to do is
because it's just the nature of our
system because there's such a bias
against their parties what we really
need to do is harness all that energy to
fix things and just try to take over the
existing infrastructure because you're
not gonna build a counter infrastructure
because there's so much name recognition
it's like saying there's democrat and
there's republican yeah technically we
could start up RC Cola and see if we
could get a significant market share but
you're not gonna do it you're not gonna
do it it's not gonna work so really and
again i don't want this to be the answer
but just factually speaking it is the
answer that we have to try to overtake
you know the corrupt elements within the
system and and bring about change that
way cuz that's the only way i think it
will really work well the only way it's
gonna really work is if what you were
talking about with
on very specific issues because if you
the most of the things that are problems
are not benefiting people they're
benefiting the people that are in
positions of power and positions where
they can influence the way policy is
dictated because they've contributed to
campaigns and because they've got this
sort of revolving door thing going on
with universities where mathematics
professors and economic professor is
sort of dictate policy or or advise and
then they get jobs and banks and then
you've got this whole weird thing going
on with people in the government right
that's right listen I mean that was
exposed in what was that the inside job
inside job which you're a fantastic
documentary for people to understand the
collapse but you it's not benefiting us
all these things that happen and all
this corruption that takes place and all
this influence doesn't it never benefits
us it's only exactly right but that's
what's weird about it and if we got a
chance to vote on most of these ideas
instead of voting on politicians and
then the politicians implement these
ideas to benefit themselves and benefit
the special interest groups who got them
into place then things would be much
better
[Applause]